[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
seventy years ago this week China
started down the path of communist rule
over the past few decades China has
emerged or rather re-emerged as a
leading world power rivaling the u.s.
the Communist Party can rightfully claim
a string of stunning successes but
challenges remain what's next for
China's extraordinary revolution
[Music]
crosswalking China's Revolution at 70
I'm joined by my guest Fred tang in New
York he is president of the American of
Public Affairs Institute in Hong Kong we
have Andrew learning he is an
international and independent China
strategist and in Knoxville we cross
this era shoe she is CEO of China rising
capital forecast a research technology
company all right cross that grows in
effect that means you can jump in in any
time you want and I always appreciate
Sarah let me go to you first in
Knoxville the 70th anniversary of the
Communist China the advent and
establishment of the communist state of
China is a remarkable event it out the
Soviet Union only lasted 69 and now
China is at 70 and there's so much to
talk about there's so many successes and
there's so many challenges if you're the
average person in China if there is such
a thing what are they thinking on this
day go ahead Sarah I think that people
are generally interested in celebrating
this day it's certainly an exciting time
it's a major anniversary and I think
people are generally happy with their
living circumstances they're wealthier
than they've ever been it's definitely
something that in 1949 people could not
have imagined would be the case and I
think generally there's a celebratory
feeling in the air okay Fred that's kind
of the same question because what do
they what is the Communist Chinese light
a leadership what are they most proud of
70 years on go ahead Fred well I think
that China in the last 70 years over
three stages the first is the first 30
years there's a lot of challenges that's
it and then we have a ten year period
and they try to open up to the west and
identify their work so the really is the
last 30 years that they have elevated
three 600 million people are the
property they're still working on it
their science the technology the
infrastructure every way education for
all the people and like Sarah said the
the people are very very proud and this
is the time for them to look back and
see how far they have come now there's
challenges but also looking back it make
you realize where you are
and I think that's that's what's going
on in China you know Andrew but it's
only been in the last couple of years
that China has seen as a a threat a
growing threat a challenge to the
international order and in Western media
is particularly very unkind to China
remarkably so that there's a lot of
people that talk about China that don't
know much about it I have a panel that
know a lot about it and have a much more
nuanced view of China the world is the
world celebrating along with the Chinese
70 years on go ahead Andrew
well you've got to trace back history a
little right back to ten eleven Square
and of course the whole world rose up
against a communist China which is
authoritarian suppressing his people and
so on and so forth but now
FastTrack miracle and there came a Nixon
and also Henry Kissinger and there came
a period a honeymoon period whereby the
United States wanted China on their side
so as to floss the rise of Russia and so
that there came a honeymoon period in
the asylum China relationship and then
also our force for the Looby China was
moved into the WTO the World Trade
Organization because it was felt that by
bringing China into the WTO China could
produce all the there all the the cheap
products and production could be
outsourced to China and then all the the
the cheap products to benefit the
chocolate the American consumers and
then also it's the hope that China would
be it be more like the West yes is born
will become more liberal and then could
be even more democratic
but then after so many years this hook
was was lost I mean the the United
States of nowit's after the fact that
China is not like the United States and
by any means and not only is is is not
producing the t-shirts and like issues
anymore is now trying to eat Americans
lunch in 5g technology and so on and so
forth and and so and
fear that there is a rising power with a
different regime with values at odds
with those in the West you know sort of
that fits into a rhetoric over China
threat and then this translates into 360
degrees pushback against China across
the aisle yeah well Sarah I mean it
wasn't in really naive because I thought
it was naive is that we'll get them in
the WTO and they'll all become good
Jeffersonian democracy which is
ridiculous here why should China change
its culture for the dominant power the
United States okay it worked within the
WTO it's a unbelievable success stories
on so many different fronts again there
are a lot of challenges and a lot of
challenges are facing them now because
of their success I would say here but it
was naive that they were going to become
like the West
why should Chinese become Westerners
that's a question that is not often
asked in Washington go ahead Sarah well
China is sort of the case that proves
all of the other cases wrong that is
that economies that are growing have to
be democratic China went against the
grain for that and I think that the West
lost hopes to some extent that China
would change its authoritarian regime
after chandaman Square happened in 1989
I think for the WTO entry that
Westerners believe that China would open
up its economy fast which it has in
terms of trade but it's been far less
less quick in terms of financial
liberalisation and I think that you know
that's something that a lot of
Westerners are disappointed in and
Westerners have seemed to come to terms
with China's status as a communist
nation up until the recent
administration trump administration in
the US and some some bad feelings also
in Europe due to a trade differences
yeah but it wasn't until recently that
the West started to call out China and
view them as being somewhat in the wrong
yeah I mean Fred it was it's interesting
to me that it's only been in the last
year or so that if you look at the
mainstream media they you
okay decade and a half it was China
China's rising China is developing it's
expanding look at the success of the
Chinese but it's all in the last year's
now the communist regime of China is a
threat to the United States
I mean they've actually kind of changed
the rhetoric here because they're
looking for
well of course China is a threat to the
Western order because it doesn't want to
play by its rules I don't see why China
should you need to negotiate you need to
I deal with each other in good faith
that's how you're going to move forward
here but it's our way or the highway and
that doesn't go down well the country
that is successful is China Fred well I
think that that's true and then that
however it didn't start really from the
Trump administration I think in globally
there is a nationalism and there's a lot
of dissatisfaction with their own
government yeah using China as a
scapegoat it's one way that this
administration is doing I think that if
you're looking at in terms of the world
order or even the definition of
democracy I think that all nations
should have a role in terms of defining
this right now the current way of even
defining democracy is by a very few
country who were the victors of the
Second World War but they're not
including China or Russia into that
discussion and that definition is set
however there might not be you know
right for everybody a suitable for
everybody earlier you know when when
Andy was talking about in terms of the
the other nations I do think that China
is respected by a lot of countries
except the few Western nations I think
that's very true because Andrew I mean
if you if you make a comparison just in
this century in the 21st century all of
the money the Western countries
particularly the United States leading
the the Washington Consensus all the
trillions of dollars wasted on Foreign
Wars but the Chinese who spent all their
money on infrastructure not only in
their country but across the world it's
not exporting its model its economic
model or political model it's certainly
not spreading a democracy isn't it the
Chinese might understand it I mean and I
think that's a lot of the angst that
people get from
about the Chinese because the Chinese
still and is a criticism of my own still
conning say below the radar and they're
you know they're building factories here
bridges there all kinds of things around
the world and they just keep moving on
and the West everyone's well wakes up in
the middle of night and says oh my
goodness what are they doing they're
trying to conquer the world well they're
they're expanding world trade bringing
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people out of poverty I can tell you in
the part of the world that I live in the
Eurasian landmass Chinese development is
welcomed okay it creates prosperity go
ahead Andy well you look at the
experience at during the Cold War for
example I think in a way both China and
Russia and the USSR in those days we're
trying to export the common ideology
around the world and and the West saw
that as the kind of communism is trying
to overtake it suppose more the Cold War
yeah yeah but now it's no longer but now
there is a dynamic in the sense that
they support who sit at this track
whereby as anything superpower feels is
threatened by rising superpower or
claiming to be a superpower and and and
they and they especially such a
superpower a rising superpower comes
from a different ideological system and
as one high-ranking US and a White House
adviser a lady who said Oh Bernie I said
well this is a threat coming from a
modern Caucasian culture so it's always
a class of civilizations you know so and
you you have these two forces coming at
the head now with just not you know
happened before let's go to Sarah last
20 seconds in this block go ahead Sarah
real quick yeah I actually would contest
the idea that China's China's ideology
can just perpetuate itself I think that
the economy has run up against some
limitations in terms of like the
government's intervention in the
me and so I think that China will come
up to its own barriers in terms of its
ideology politically that will prevent
it from growing further economically
okay it's a very good point I want to
return to that we're going to go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on China's
revolution 70 years on stake with our
tea
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered on Peter LaBelle
to remind you were discussing China's
revolution
[Music]
okay let's go back to Sara in Knoxville
before we went to the break sir you said
some something really fascinating to me
about what that what kind of barriers
that china is going to face I guess in
the next 70 years of its revolution
expand on some of those points and some
of those problems go ahead sir right so
there are limitations to market forces
in China and we see this in the stock
market we see this all throughout the
financial sector where there is sort of
a ceiling on the level of profit that
people can make simply because there's a
lot of government involvement if
anything goes bad the government gets
involved if there's a bubble the
government could intervene and in
addition to that a lot of the companies
that are listed on the Chinese stock
market are affiliated with the Chinese
government and so they're not growing as
fast a lot of academic studies have
shown that a lot of state-owned bags of
state-owned enterprises have fewer
market forces than private enterprises
China's private sector is still
relatively small and even though it's
continuing to grow so I think that in
the next maybe even ten years China is
going to face some barriers to further
growth simply because it needs more
competition it needs more market forces
it needs to be able to generate
innovation without fear of potential
crackdown or reprisal on on some of the
riskier ideas and so it could be really
problematic
you know it's continue with that theme
Fred you know the the the the Communist
Party of China in it I would argue it
gleans a lot of its legitimacy because
of so much success over the last few
decades pulling so many people out of
poverty I mean you know and as and
Andrew pointed out early in the program
you know they just don't make Adidas
shoes and t-shirts anymore they make
some really remarkable high-tech things
here what do you think the Chinese
government is gonna do to in facing that
challenge because I think sarah laid it
out really well go ahead Fred yeah I
kind of disagree with Sarah because I
think that if Martin were alive today he
would not recognize the Harmony Party of
today
neither would Tung champagne even though
he was the one who said open and reform
policy he would not have seen so
for that the country have come so far
with his policy that I do nothing he was
imagine the success it has achieved so
in terms of saying that the Communist
Party or the Chinese government does not
change that's wrong if we look at every
ten years they have made dramatic
changes and making those changes at the
same time creating stability within the
society and moving ahead so I would see
that they were further be opening up
however without creating chaos without
creating a bubble in the in the stock
market and without pretty disastrous or
financial degree with that okay Sara
jump in that's the point of the program
that's the point of the program go ahead
yeah I would I would disagree with that
I mean the the government has
limitations and in order to stay in
power the Chinese government has to have
stern control over the economy and we
see that despite market opening up the
government has remained in control of
state-owned enterprises has really
focused on them in the past few years in
terms over for and it's something that
is innately connected with a communist
government I don't think that China will
be able to get out of that and allow
market forces to entirely prevail I
think it's gonna remain a problem okay
let me go to Andrew I mean I don't think
maybe I'll surprise all of you but I
don't worship the markets okay because
the markets do get skewed okay and I'm
really glad that there are controls
there to a point okay to a point I think
I would agree with Sarah that sometimes
government regulations and controls can
make an economy brittle and not be able
to expand in the way it should
okay nonetheless Andrew there's nothing
that succeeds like success and so you
know when I look at the last major trade
agreement that the US and the Chinese
were working on and then it suddenly
collapsed because essentially the United
States wants to dictate the terms and
conditions of reforms in some sectors of
the Chinese economy we're talking about
China here not Panama no offense to
Panama but I mean China is a power to be
reckoned with why should the United
States that or any other power be
dictating the internal structures of the
financial secretary other
a sectors of the economy what why should
kind of be dictated to when it can say
no go ahead Andrew well I like to follow
up on your reference to nothing succeeds
like success because that's exactly what
the Communist Party is trying to do this
keeps on revent
reinventing yourself so the Communist
Party nowadays it's not the same as the
Communist Party at the time of Chairman
Mao in terms of the attitude towards
private enterprise and the attitudes was
the market and so and so forth and III
agree with the notion that stating
enterprise is going to remain for a long
long time and this is part of the
communist ideology out their faith and
that in fact the state plays a very
important role in driving private
enterprise for example there is a degree
of the invisible hand as aware of the
state is even in democracies like the
United States where think about the
success of the invention of the internet
for example without state intervention
in the military research I mean this may
not have happened or at least not
happened so fast and you could even look
at now a countries like France there are
sailor and state-owned enterprises you
know some of the big because the French
banks are a state owned so I think the
state-owned enterprise is not a monopoly
of communism but I think the challenges
ahead I'd like to refer to another big
dimension the fact that China supports
perspective for the remarkable
achievements over all these years in
fact if you look at the period it's not
seventy years because try to only open
up in 1979 in 40 years it's complete
change but then but then chocolate
although China's perspective turn is not
liked by a lot of countries even
research in attitudes in Africa where
China's investment spring a lot of
benefits the current attitude towards
China's mix and it because the greatest
deficit
in China's and trajectory it's soft
power
you know what the soft power mean it
means soft power institutions are the
kind of institutions that can provide
some sort of a check and balance the
sort of the institution to regulate the
market for example and and and open up
the market without stifling it and also
curbing the visible hand of the state so
it has to be the right mix okay I'm
gonna come halfway with you and that has
to be done right and that is and that is
very very nuanced you know the first
stages of China opening up and
developing its economy that's like what
primitive accumulation that's it's it's
not hard to do as long as you give it
the conditions but when it becomes more
and more intensive than that I do worry
about government regulation let me let
me go back to Sara Sara
during the last 40 years that know that
and II just mention there China really
surged upward and there wasn't a whole
lot of attention there wasn't this sense
that it was a rival that's a relatively
new idea right now how is that going to
change the dynamic of how the Communist
Party rules and how is it going to
change the dynamic about how the economy
grows because it's an it's an
export-oriented economy it's the factory
of the world it's an amazing phenomenon
ok but that's being tested right now the
through synergies trap is already
mentioned on this program and it's it is
it's invoked a lot recently for good
reason because the US is watching go
ahead Sara yeah I think that China has
been increasingly defensive particularly
with the Trump administration because
it's you know the Trump administration
is saying look at made in China 2025 you
know you guys are having like a
government-funded move towards high
technology that could undermine our own
interest and so China is being
increasingly defensive and really trying
not to call out other players on the
world stage but just trying to justify
its own existence I think it's gonna
have to do more than
going forward in terms of economics I
would say that China also finds itself
in defensive mode particularly with us
at this point and you know it's because
it's some of its firms are high tech
firms it's something that the government
is very much behind and these high tech
firms are finding themselves in the
crosshairs of US economic policy such as
Huawei and you know so this is gonna be
problematic for China it's going to have
to figure out how to negotiate this
without looking like it's going to
dominate the world and I know that a lot
of people are very nervous about one
belt one road view it as a big war but
military power can I even though it
doesn't necessarily have the capacity
for that well let me ask you a question
since you brought it up we'll use your
words this China want to rule the world
do you really believe that no I don't
think so
you know people view China the West is
increasingly viewing China's such yeah
but let me go to Fred but you know I
mean Andrew brought it up again he
brought it up first before I did I when
I look at how the Western media treats
China there is an implicit racism in
there all of the time and it's really
extraordinary from these liberal media
outlets but they do sound racist because
a non Caucasian on Western power is is
challenging the current paradigm and I
don't see any reason why the Chinese are
gonna look backwards because they have a
whole lot to look forward to as the West
tears itself up over ridiculous
ideological things I don't want to go
into it because I get sick and tired of
hearing about it but China has every
reason to look forward last minute goes
to Fred yes I totally agree with you
it's a lot of racism going on not only
against China also against Chinese
Americans in the United States people
always think that we're looking at these
Chinese people how can they do so well
they must be stealing this is not true
early on you have talked about China
being an export country which is also
changing right now China this GDP 80
percent is domestic 20 percent is export
a United States account for 30% of that
20 percent so it's a total of 6
percent of China's total GDP have
related to the United States they're
working with the rest of the world and
and they're moving ahead
I just wanted at one more point about
state-owned enterprises stay on
enterprises are what we call the
dragonhead industries every country need
dragonhead industries for it to sustain
itself you know I use the word for a
dragon hair industry called a TNT when
United States break up big companies
like that they were breaking up its own
infrastructure today's if today we have
Google Amazon you know Facebook if we
break up those industry we will have
another dynamic changes in the United
States okay go for the ball right I
think Freddie's ending the program with
Touche and I agree with them to a large
degree many thanks to my guests in New
York Hong Kong and in Knoxville and
thanks to our viewers for watching us
here at RT see you next time remember
crosstalk rules
[Music]